hello and welcome
with a new start gate series hopefully
on the horizon i want to have a chat
about canon
and like i said with a new series coming
how much cannon is important and how
much can we forgive welcome to sci track
your sci-fi tv a movie channel
[Music]
hey everybody and welcome i'm gone live
today to have this conversation mainly
because i don't want to just talk at you
about this subject i actually want your
feedback and we've already had some
really good comments which we'll we'll
go through at the end but
canon
how important is canon how much can we
forgive what types of canon errors are
there and for this discussion i'm going
to compare stargate and star trek and
this isn't going to be a star trek
bashing video i personally am a trekkie
i love star trek stargate is my favorite
series i won't lie but i do love star
trek
but canon and canon errors and canon
well to be honest when shows completely
appeal over canon has changed things for
random stuff
um does drive me up the wall and i'm
gonna explain to you why by the way guys
i got a new microphone tell me if you
can hear me okay
so oh also i'm still getting over a bit
of a head cold so if i get a bit at
times please ignore me hey shelley we
have shelley is in the house so if we
get any um
crazy
bad people in today shelly will be on
you all right so watch it
right so first of all
stargate and canon
i put a comment on the community page
ages ago now saying
can anybody actually think of a time
when stargate
badly messed up canon
and the only example i got well i got
two examples to be fair i got the
difference between the movie the
original stargate movie kurt russell etc
and then the series there were some
quite major differences
um but that's to be honest
understandable they they went from a
movie format to a tv series the the
movie was never written to be an opener
to a series so
things had to be changed things had to
be fleshed out and there were certain
elements of the gold for example it just
didn't make sense so that had to be
changed but that for me completely
forgivable and understandable
the only example anybody could come up
with
for um
you know for the way
um stargate failed on cannon was one
that somebody had a zap um i think it
was tilk and he fired it without it
opening first and that was the only
example anybody could come up with and
um
to be honest that's a production error
that's a continuity error
it's not even really a canon error for
me
um but then i started to think about
star trek and but the reason why i want
to have this conversation is because as
i said hopefully with a new stargate
series on the horizon
we should look at what they've done with
star trek and new trek even though we're
going to go back further than that
because i think there's been massive
cannon errors even further back than
that
and we could learn from it and stargate
hopefully we'll learn from it but also
we can have a think about what
would we be willing to forgive and then
i will get into the comments a little
later and um you know we'll we'll start
having a conversation about that
so star trek continuity errors
we can ignore
jj abrams all the star trek of jj abrams
because they had the it's a different
timeline excuse
incredibly lazy writing doesn't explain
though why in the first movie second
movie in the third movies the warp drive
the way the warp core was was completely
different
in each movie
that doesn't explain that it doesn't
explain why all of a sudden the
enterprise was 30 times bigger than um
it was in the original series it doesn't
explain that
um
you know
okay the other the things that changed
fine it doesn't explain why you suddenly
have a transporter technology that can
beam you um at trans warp across the
entire galaxy from earth to kronos
um
if you're not a trek fan then you have
no idea what i'm talking about but um
but you still need starships apparently
um so it doesn't understand why like
that technology again in the next
generation they couldn't even um warp
and while you couldn't even transport
from one ship to another wallet warp it
was incredibly dangerous and so
from one solar system to the other
um
so that was crazy so yeah if we ignore
jj abrams completely
good films not star trek
um we get into the
debate about new trek but i'm even gonna
go further back than that
there were canon errors in the original
series
there were canon errors in the next
generation i mean a big one being we
moaned about how much they changed the
klingons
um for discovery they did that in next
generation as well
and they had a brilliant episode where
they said it was a genetic thing and you
know but but they did it and we didn't
get too angry about it and i think we
got more angry about it because they did
it badly in discovery and made them all
look creepy um the klingons just looked
weird but in in next generation look
pretty cool so we forgave it you know um
but again
those continuities go way back
the continuities that would bug me
though
are historical continuity errors and
canon errors so when they do things like
in um i think it was called minefield in
enterprise and they
talked about the romulans having
cloaking technology
even though in the original series we
see
the klingon sorry the romulans used
cloaking technology first time and
everybody was so shocked so in the
original series which is set after
enterprise
they had we had never seen clogging
technology but it in existed so that's
just a cock-up
and then another cloak in error cock-up
is that um the romulans invented
cloaking technology apparently and the
klingon stole it but then in discovery
they have cloaking technology before so
again even before enterprise they had
cloaking technology so okay makes uh not
sorry before and twice before the next
the original series again so again these
these errors are completely
um
stupid and
could be
fixed
but why do they happen
a big problem with enter with star trek
in particular i think is they keep doing
prequels
and if you're going to set a series
before
the series that followed it so if you're
going to set a series like strangely
wolves before the original series you
better know what happened in the
original series you better have a really
geeky story writer that knows all of the
plots inside and out and knows where you
can and where you can't step on toes
if you don't have that and you've just
got somebody that's read the story once
they're going to write brilliant stories
but those stories will then not make
sense when they're compared to the other
series
so my first hope for a new stargate
series is they don't do a prequel
or if they do do a prequel do it like a
million years ago so that it's not
really a major problem for canada excuse
me
um
also thing if you're going to do that is
remember if you introduce a character
and you introduce their family that you
then don't just randomly add relatives
um like they have done with spock
repeatedly he's got brothers and sisters
and half brothers and sisters he's
completely forgotten about
um you know it's just like
it just doesn't doesn't make sense at
all
um
sorry
so yeah so don't do that either um
vulcans very forgettable when it comes
to half brothers and things they just
they just completely they forget about
it
there is canon errors though in star
trek that i can kind of forgive
so
in discovery they one developed a hollow
deck which did irritate me a little bit
because that that didn't exist in the
original series and you know only
appeared in the next generation but the
one thing they did do though is they
also had hollow communication so they
would you could project a hologram now
we saw that for the first time in deep
space nine but then they had it in
discovery
but i can kind of understand why
because
communication just on a big screen back
in the 80s or 90s even was impossible so
it was still science fiction
we couldn't have like face-to-face
communication through a screen
now it's normal we all face time it's
only in the last
10 years even that not less than that
really that it's become normal it's
possible so all of a sudden just talking
somebody through a screen isn't science
fiction anymore it's it's normal and
boring
so they edited the technology so that
the future which still future compared
to us of discovery still seemed
futuristic
i don't mind that so much in that it you
know you change things but you do it so
that it fits
um
culture and it fits normal life so i
think so it still seems like science
fiction
i do mind historical errors though if
you write something into a story
it should still be true you know you
shouldn't have things that they just
completely change
so another example
when we have a new stargate series the
goal world should be the same
but it wouldn't bother me if they
changed the style or the way they look
what it would bother me though if they
changed the traits of the
gold so the gold should still be quite
power hungry they should still be
generally quite greedy and selfish
creatures
um they should be evil to a to a degree
um and then we've got the takrah which
are you know the the the flip side of
that different philosophy so we should
still have that we shouldn't change
their traits
like they did to the klingons in star
trek where they completely particularly
discovery really changed what the
klingons were not just how they looked
and how their ships were designed and
things they changed the culture they
changed so much about that character
now you can we talk about woke ideology
and things like this um
which is not a conversation i like to
have but i think elements of that do
come into it that they're trying to make
a point about sexuality and all these
sorts of things um and they're using
this alien species as a way to do that
um
star trek and sci-fi has always been
woken it should always be woke i think
the orville is a really good example of
that if you watch the first episode of
the last series it's woke as hell but
it's written really really well
so it works and it's not ran down your
throat
star trek picard episode two has a big
point in it um
it's gerardi and somebody else in there
um they make a there's a big point about
racism and how racism is rife in the
21st century but it stuck out in the
episode like sore thumb it was just like
the story's going along story's going
along
big
anti-racism comment over here and then
oh let's go back to the story but a
point you know that that's not how it
should be done and it wasn't necessarily
because they made the point it was
because they made the point really badly
um so for me sci-fi should always be
woke um but it should be woke done well
and subtly
um should have layers to it but you
shouldn't necessarily know what all
those layers are in the first say
because they have to point them out to
you you know it shouldn't be like that
so
have character traits
but when you establish a character and
you establish a species or a gin it
should stay the same right the ferengi
should not all of a sudden grow a
conscience
um you know the replicator shouldn't all
of a sudden start building things the
borg shouldn't all of a sudden um
actually be really worried about
defending humanity you know just it's
just these things don't make sense don't
do it keep it the same
if you want to create a new villain or a
new
um or if you're not you know
if you want to like say um an existing
species say and change it to make a
point create a new species
don't mess with the one we know
so again i'm hoping stargate when it
comes back if they do make changes to
species like the gold things that we
know
don't do it in a way that's too
aggressive
and that changes things
but
would we accept some changes so now i'm
going to get into the comments now
and have a look at what people have been
saying because i haven't i've been
trying to
purposefully not read them too much
because it can do anything but i've
pretty much told you what i think on
this one
um we mentioned the prequels we
mentioned things we mentioned like the
little errors in stargate that we don't
really mention
um but what can we forgive oh by the way
the canon areas i can think of are
technological canon errors we've talked
about that already historical canon eras
we talk about character traits and
things and the style and look of things
and the style look of things i just do
does have to evolve because we do need
to shake things up a little bit the
starships are going to look different in
the new series of stargate and so they
should you know um we it
it's got to have a modern style to it
technology and the way the cgi works and
look is different today so that is going
to affect how the show looks
if you're expecting stargate
new series to look like sgu sga or sg1
you're going to be very very
disappointed because it's not going to
look the same it's going to have a very
different style and like i said so it
should
um
there's always this argument between
there's this danger between you've got
to have things that are similar enough
that the existing fans are happy
but different enough that you can
attract new fans
and that it's not boring because you're
just thinking you're just sat there
watching well i've just watched this
performance i've just watched you one
again so you've got to make dumbs do
some changes
but let's get into the um thing right so
some of the glitch
first message before i even start the
video
well done uh canon is important to me
but canon leaps as i call them can be
fun the difference between the original
series tmp tng um make them great
thought and discussion enterprise two to
a lesser extent yeah i know what you're
saying
and when they make changes but i think
um dax has a really good point here if
you watch a three-part episode in the
first episode is wart drive the second
was quantum slip tree in the third
episode is a folding holtzman drive like
juno event verizon
what is the point
it's like watching a sporting event and
yeah i love this example for basketball
using ice skates and bowling shoes
tomorrow it yeah it's completely that
right if you're going to have something
like that
have some continuity to it or it just
doesn't make any sense
um star wars new series um i've only
watched the first episode of um
obi-wan
and i'm already really confused by it
um
i i thought it would be
a series i i don't understand why they
brought the young princess layer in it
that makes no sense to me why do that
i know he's supposed to be watching him
but doesn't he meet her
that seems strange um
[Music]
yeah
it should be about ben trying to
get over what's happened
rather than
what it is about and i don't know it
just it seems like
thing please hit the chat yeah
yes please ignore jj abrams
i think what you have to do with the jj
abrams movies and i mentioned this
earlier but i think it's really really
important
is enjoy them as entertaining movies as
action movies almost don't think i'm a
star trek
if you don't think i'm a star trek
they're really good sci-fi movies if you
think i'm a star trek you will get angry
i haven't said basically too much today
something
by the way there is um a link in the
description for uh merchandising and
there's a good couple of stargate
t-shirts on there my first one i've
picked a team i've done an sg1 sgu and
sga
uh t-shirt and logo you know the glasses
different as well um drop the prices as
much as i possibly can so i don't make
much money on them um and the delivery
actually is pretty good it's only a
couple of quid so even if you're in the
uk it's only a couple of quid so um
please get on there support the channel
and get a cool t-shirt out of it
um
makeup technology budget loud tng clean
guns yeah exactly the
that is a good point as well the main
reason why they changed the klingons was
because they could
in the original series it was you know a
bit of
face paint and um you know messed the
eyebrows and put a wig on and they had
no money so when they needed the
romulans they're just like let's use the
wigs again
and you know that all of a sudden they
had the they had the budget
and the skill and you know and the time
to do something completely different so
they did
um and they did something that looked
really
cool in the
discovery obviously they they had the
ability to do a bit more
and they kept
it's like
a few years ago china was making a lot
of cars um but they were actually
ripping off a lot of european cars
because i have got a point to this by
the way i will get there um but they
were making them quite badly but because
the courts in china would never support
if like um bmw whatever sued a chinese
car company to say well you're copying
our car um these chinese companies just
got away with it for years and they made
these cars that look really random but
it was like the one was like a it was
like a copy of a mini
um but it was badly copied it was like
somebody had seen a mini once
and then a few years later was asked to
draw one in crayon
and then they made the car from it
that's what this this other car looked
like um that's what they kind of did
with klingons and discovery it was like
somebody who ever designed the klingons
had gone um oh do you have sinus or
klingon do the makeup for the klingons
will you and they were like i i saw the
next generation 20 years ago i haven't
seen any ages they had a ridge thing
didn't they some sort of ridge thing and
then they designed klingons out of it um
that is maddening though because they
did such a bad job
it was so you know they had the elements
of what a klingon was but no
nothing you know
it was just rubbish
um they're the federation band cloak now
the federation didn't actually ban
cloaking technology
it was part of the peace agreement with
the romulans um
so as part of the the same peace
agreement that set up the
neutral zone the federation also agreed
not to have cloaking technology so it
wasn't the kitten of course i was that
was the that was klingons wasn't it
somebody get into the comments and
remind me what it was but yeah so they
didn't actually ban cloaking
technologies they agreed
through the thing not to
not to have it
and stop a war this new show spock has
his wife yep
see again just completely changing
something that's never been mentioned
before but whatever soap operas are
brothers along with and whatever yeah
um
yeah the producer new klingons were
standing for the republicans
i've not heard that before but okay
um let's have a look through
[Music]
psytrek.com that's the link thank you
shelly uh she put a link up for the
facebook group as well guys if you
haven't gone on we hit a thousand
people on the facebook group i'm always
putting stuff on there trying to start
conversations silly memes and stuff a
lot of the time but there you go you can
join that as well
in discovery the klingons have just done
wrong my contribution the borg equals
the commies
kardashians the nazis and the majority
jews
he's not far off is he
really
i think that is in this point that a lot
of the time we use alien species and
things in sci-fi to reflect
certain
aspects of human
um
or different human cultures and things
and you know because it's a way of like
creating like a metaphor to explain
certain things or certain things in
history or
um
different traits within humanity you
know the frame gear about greed
and you know you could argue they're the
americans maybe you know a boiled down
version of the american dream um but
obviously taken to an extreme and then
um that helps you to tell the story so
but it's done subtly that nobody at no
point is any they don't ever have to
like tell you that
you just know through watching the show
because you're not an idiot and that's
the bit
um
a cork had his moments where he had more
humanity than he was around him these
thoughts can explain express well
yeah because that that's again though
isn't it it's when he went against his
own natural innate
um greed that all those traits were
still there though didn't he he was
still quark
but he grew
as a person he grew as a character and
that's what we want to see
but it doesn't mean he doesn't change
completely what it was to be
yeah go will still exist you're right
they are on earth as well
the lucian alliance still exists but i
don't think they're going to be a
villain in the new series
uh unless they develop some sort of
massive technological leap they've only
got gold technology
we've got asgard technology
you know so our ships the you know the
304s or you know it by now be like three
or five maybe bc305
um in the fan fiction i'm trying to
write that that's the big voice is the
three or five um but anyway um we've got
technology to cut through them like hot
knife through butter you know i had the
asgard beam technology and weapons and
the shields are much much better so
unless the lucian alliance have
developed some sort of advanced
technology
but i think the only the only reason the
gold world never really advanced
massively in the thousands of years but
they just had attacked someone have it
was because they never had to there was
never
a villain to take them on it was only
really when um
you know
while we turned up the replicators
turned up that maybe they were forced to
try to develop different technologies
um
so maybe they would advance
get a spoof of the ricky
if you're not british you'd have no clue
what that is
so
um opportunities that china brought the
mini cooper oh i just lost that
sorry guys i lost that thing china
bought the mini cooper and they own it
now they do that's that's uh no they
don't own no mg you're thinking about
minis owned by bmw ducks um so the mini
is still owned by bmw um
the chinese company bought mg
uh and they're built in china and then
sent over here and they put a british
badge on it which is very randomly
um
friendly with a caricature of my former
italian politics
[Laughter]
i drew the wraith back in high school
back in the 1970s you saw the future
that's pretty cool
um
ruben hill was i love this
i love your photo as well
very good post 2009 truck is rubbish so
glad to have stargate for good sci-fi
well that's the point of why we're
having this conversation really let's
hope that we get a new stargate and they
learn from this i would like to know you
guys i'm getting down through the
comments i know but um
where's the line for you and what what
they can change in canon
for me if they change historical things
i'm going to turn off
and if they change existing characters
or
existing species too much i think
there's a little bit of a editing
they're allowed to do
then again i'm going to turn off again
there's good example here is like the
enterprise in strange new worlds they've
changed it um by
they've said you're not allowed to
change it more than 20
and that kicked off this whole thing
about oh there's two copyrights got
nothing to do with copyright it's to do
with they've got new technology they can
generate a new
um computer generated version enterprise
and they needed to tweak the enterprise
a little bit so that it made sense and
looked right next to the discovery
because they built the description they
designed the discovery and then they
decided we're gonna have the enterprise
in it and they were oh god it looks crap
the enterprise if we keep it exactly the
same looks rubbish next to the discovery
so we're gonna have to tweak it a little
bit so they did that i don't mind if
they do that either i don't mind if they
tweak things in the new stargate series
and new designs i don't know if we get a
new gate and things like that
particularly
um as long as it's not too different if
it's a square gate or a bloody
octangular gate then i'm kicking off but
you know but where is the line
where where when does it become okay
hey christoph how are you doing sir
this he dropped the ball and they didn't
show the original season clinging on so
long they designed klingons yeah and was
a group of meat in the houses yeah
exactly it's it's just just it was just
so stupid
um
302 is my delaware call
jerry on fire tonight
i forgot which clone issue one could
still be alive yes they could
um we had an mgo as a kid parents sold
it when we could start to drive
cool
um i wouldn't mind the asgardians not
looking like the 1950 grey aliens are
more like thor odin
thank you for swearing i didn't notice
um i think that's um
that to me i would that would bother me
i don't mind if they changed them
slightly but well for one i don't think
the asgard can come back
um that would require a hard reboot
unless somebody eventually mentions what
if they come back from a different
galaxy
or is it different
you know actually that is an interesting
point one way they could change the
asgard really easily because the ant
guard is an ancient species that get
genetically modified themselves didn't
they are messing with their own genetics
and that's why they end up dying off
so we could see an asgard from another
galaxy
that look really different we could see
like
an earlier evolution
or a different evolution of the asgard
say a branch of the species that decided
to go a different way with their genetic
manipulation so
yeah we could see and that in that case
they could look like almost anything
couldn't they and it wouldn't be messing
with cannon it wouldn't be changing
anything really that's actually a really
interesting idea we could so see the
asgard come back and it'd be completely
different
um without it you know peeing all over
canada doing anything
um
leftover alright technology alan um yes
you did mention this before at sidetrack
thank you sir um
yeah they've got our technology um which
seemed to be in some ways more advanced
than the odds guard in other ways less
and their weapon systems seem to be more
advanced but then they had staff weapons
that seem to be no better than a staff
weapon the gold were using so um
they they seem to be i've been caught in
a little bit of um a technological
um mosh pit there a little bit or
they're stuck in the mud in certain
areas
um
i think there's room to re-examine
things without breaking cannon for
example people see star trek as
egotarian but maybe we're rarely shown
anyone that in in one percent of the
federation society
yeah i think that star wars is a big one
on that
i'm so sick to death of star wars
having all their episodes on tatooine
and about five different characters
there's a there's a galaxy there in star
wars
that they could explore and they just
haven't and that infuriates me and it's
the same with star trek really we
they they seem to be
so focused on it it has to be serious
about the enterprise
why
if enterprise was called
um discovery
and it was just not called the
enterprise i would have had no problem
with that series at all but they called
it enterprise and that again was a kick
in the thing because enterprise never
existed
and they got around that by calling the
nx oh it's not really an enterprise
because it's an nx it's experimental so
don't call the enterprise just call it
something else but they've got an
obsession they have to call the
enterprise we have to have kirk in the
new series of strange new worlds we have
to do we have don't just don't have a
new story have a completely different
story star wars infuriates me with that
don't do another series of touching if i
ever see tatooine in the series again
and there's supposed to be millions of
star systems
go on any of them just one different one
um
in real world be aware millions of mars
people muslim versus but moon is almost
exclusive military base to prevent
secret space force okay
yeah i wonder if thor's blood could be
used to fix sg1's thor's dna problem no
the asgard was in the pegasus wasn't it
they were they were in species in
atlantis so that would be something
we've seen before
um
and and didn't they look the same
atlantis says i haven't watched atlantis
in years i'm just watching stargate sg1
again next week we're having a stagger
issue on series 2 review which we're
looking at the whole series um live um
matt is joining us for that
um
and but i will get to atlantis again so
i will brush up on atlantis but i'm
pretty sure they look the same didn't
they weren't they're the greys the same
so i would maybe want to see
them from another galaxy
ghost ghost completely off
off topic
mars attacks apparently is getting the
series
um tim burton is in early pre-production
of actually doing a mars attack series
i would love that as long as tim burton
has anything to do with it i can't stand
tim burton
he has really great ideas and then he
stamps the timber in style on it and
ruins them um
a nightmare before christmas i every
time i watch that film
i it actually almost makes me physically
angry because i'm like this is such a
good idea it should be so much better
than it is
um and i think that was the same as like
it sounds like the first batman tim
burton did and it was like he wasn't a
massively famous director then so it was
like he was he was penned in a little
bit he wasn't allowed to go full tim
burton on it and it's an amazing movie
you can still see it's a tim burton
movie but he didn't go fulton burn that
then became the biggest highest grossing
movie of all time and he was allowed to
do whatever he wanted and then we got
batman too about my returns
um and he's ruined everything ever since
he really does my edit i'm uh we're
about to get um
beetlejuice too and they'll probably
ruin that as well
they're not so sweet they don't exist
perhaps asgard that is an instant area
for the thing and i think um an
interesting idea
would be to bring the furlings
into
this new series of stargate properly but
i would almost like to see the feelings
as a bad guy as the villain
um i know they're one of the original
species and one of the four but um
and we've seen we've we've seen hints of
them but we've never seen them properly
and they can't be like the ewoks however
much
jack o'neill thinks that's what they
should look like
um
star wars disney's is very litigious
um but um but i think i think they could
come back i think the knocks we've seen
enough of them to know that they can't
they they will they're not that
interested
um there are weird species they're full
of contradictions and to be honest i
think if you tried to do a series with
an option too much it wouldn't make any
sense um because you know we see them
with all the straw hair and like living
like simple and then he goes like whoa
and the this the very advanced city
cloaks and i'm like there's
contradictions there they don't really
make sense
the feelings we know almost nothing
about though other than their name keeps
popping up and we've seen they've got
advanced technology we don't know where
they are we don't know what they look
like
to me that would be a really easy
come in but they come in and you think
they're the good guys and then bam
they're the bad guys you know that would
be i think that would be a really way of
doing it
um a total reboot um could start with
raiders the los arc whether they get the
gate instead yeah if um we have been
promised we're not gonna get a total
reboot
but
with everything that's gone on in the
last couple of months
and now amazon have completely took
control and um it sounds like at the
moment just to review if you haven't if
you don't know this already i've told
you a few times but at the moment amazon
are restructuring mgm and it looks like
they're actually
taking mgm apart
and what i'm told is nothing is
happening with any of these tv shows
but amazon have set up little teams of
two or three people and per project and
they're reviewing
all of the proposed projects mgm had in
the works at the moment and one of those
is stargate so stargate is under a
review process at the moment brad
wright's script is still sat there
um even though amazon were the ones that
it seems like actually asked mgm to do
the script in the first place they were
what they were um potentially going to
be the customer they were actually
asking mgm to do it before the sale went
through before the sales even agreed
they were thinking we'd quite like
stargate and amazon prime um
so
and they did feed back to the brad
wright's original pilot during the
development process
there's always been voices and i've
heard rumors a lot of times that they
were never quite happy with what was
produced
so there's two
risks with that
one they just go and they just get a
completely new team and they just
completely scrap brad wright's project
and but but they keep it as a soft
reboot
they could go with bradwick's project
um or my third option they do a hard
reboot
um and everything i've ever heard was
amazon don't want to do that because you
know illinois fans it'll really annoy
fans
so they don't want to do that and
everything they've ever said you can
look we'll go back to roland emrick's
comments a little while ago that he was
looking at maybe doing a movie
and but he and they wanted roland emrick
to come back to talk to mgm and talk to
them about maybe
doing something but he said i didn't
want to do it because it was very clear
to me that it was the tv fans that
mattered and when they were talking
about canon
and they didn't want to mess around with
canon too much so he said he didn't want
to do that he wanted to do something
completely different
and
and the amazon executives basically
wouldn't let them do it
so that reassures me that we're not
going to get a harder reboot but
who knows at the moment
problem with hollywood is is that
writings and producers are so lazy woke
us up
it's beneath them wokism is a new word
for me it's been a cannon doesn't gel
with diversity
i i i will agree with i'd like to say i
i don't agree i think scifi should be
woke
but i think it shouldn't be forced on us
and i think sci-fi should talk about
transgender issues it should talk about
racism it should talk about all these
things because these are problems in our
society today and it should talk about
it but it should do in a subtle way
that's that's the bit where i agree with
people who get really angry about woke
i will make the point though
some people use woke as an excuse to be
a racist
and that annoys me they and they let
slip sometimes with their
ideology and that they're using woke as
a shield and they'll have very good
um
reasons why they don't like something
they don't like a character but then
they will just mention that characters
color just one too many times or their
gender one too many times
and you you know that's when
their real agenda sneaks through
so just be careful that i agree with a
lot of people when they talk about star
trek in particular like that mentioned
early in picard episode two
it's completely still like saw film it
was probably a woke agenda
um but just be careful with it is my
advice on that one
um
so
let's go back to your thing i would like
to see a civilization that saw destiny
as a threat from halfway across the
galaxy and worked in a new threat yeah
i've just done a video about how i think
sg1 sga and sgu could come together as a
foundation for the new series but
that'll be up later in the week
um
i've missed something here yeah that's a
good idea young chronicles filling the
character would be really cool
um
a prequel for stargate is that i have
100 missed something there sorry
um
do it
my risk is though that that is you you
really have to have a super fan to write
something like that i'd love to see like
origin stories and things like this but
they have to be done
really really well um and you know this
is why i think with with stargate
actually a prequel series based on the
ancients could work because we could
learn so much about it could add to
canon um and it could add to a lot of
these stories we've already had
and you could do the same with
characters you know we could see a young
jack o'neill or something um
but obviously it wouldn't be really
sci-fi with jack o'neal because jack
o'neil's first
introduction to the gate was in the
movie and before that he was just a
soldier so it would be a soldier series
in that case if they tried to make it
sci-fi that's when you start penal over
cannon
and that's what other series have done
in the past they've just rewritten
history um
i also think about things like the solo
movie and you're just like you just
you're just at risk
um
let's bring show the west african i
don't know
most people go ahead hit that like
button people
always supreme stormlord you're a legend
thank you very much sir
origins was terrible
origins was terrible
it but
it was done
it was a bit ahead of its time origins i
think
it was almost like trying to be a
streaming series
they saw that the internet was getting
big and they thought we'll do a series
for the internet
um and but it was ahead of its time so
it had no money and and it was just it
was done it was done very rushed and
they almost did it like as if no one
will really watch it don't worry about
it only the hardcore fans will watch it
so don't stress it and they just they
didn't do a very good job
but um there are ways that that that
could have been done better but i i
think origins was ahead of its time they
could do that again i but again i'm not
really interested in that time frame
it's boring nothing really happened they
dug the stargate up and then did nothing
with it for 30 years it's not so
interesting so i'm i'm not i'm not
bothered
um an origin story for me would have to
be around the ancients i want to see
things like how
did the ancient ori conflict start how
did the um plague play out um you know
things like that there are really
interesting storylines that we've had
glimpses of through stargate sg1 is
usually um that i'd love to see fleshed
out in a proper series and now streaming
services you can do it because you can
have like eight eight episodes one-off
series doing story and you couldn't do
that before you know um you had to had
24-22 episode series they didn't they
didn't do mini series very often
streamer services you can you can do
these little one-off series and and you
know tell different stories and things
um
one contribution to canada starts
clinton's romulus descended from dying
race of vulcans uh well the romulans did
they were they were um cousins weren't
they technically
uh yes the atlantis are little women i
thought they were
um
i would not put grey's in history it
would be auto rejected
like star was training the story that
was origins right
so thanks guys for um getting in um
i don't think we've quite figured out um
ideas character continuous compelling
stories if any stargazers could retain
those four elements from there then it
would be great for a hit series
yeah it's that it's it's the genie in
the bottle i've just noticed your
picture tony that is amazing well then
um that's the genie the bottle isn't it
you have characters you've got to have
the right characters that's the magic
that's the lightning but it's hard to
capture isn't it
all right guys thank you so much
if you are new to the channel don't
forget to like and subscribe and hit the
bell notification
please go and join us on the facebook
group like i say we have a thousand
people on there now i want to see more
people on there adding your stuff asking
questions um it's it is very much the uh
the jamie channel sometimes it's just a
lot of my stuff so get on there and
actually let's have a community let's
have a couple of arguments
don't forget that the discord is on
there as well there's a link to that
through the facebook group please go and
join the discord there's loads of
conversations there matt does a really
really good job
of adding lots of quizzes and things as
well which is really interesting
please go and buy a t-shirt
every little help
every little penny helps
any contribution to the channel really
helps if i want to keep doing this i
need to make a little bit of money and
i'm afraid
um or the wife won't let me do it
anymore
so maybe the first meme to an agent has
gotten the destinies part of that story
too you could reuse expand the setter
with the sgu wrap up yeah potentially
i think he's talking about me in this
show
i'll start again
but
stargaze star wars star trek
they're the big three the big daddies
the one thing i'm going to leave you
with is that i was told again by a new
source that i've been talking to him
that doesn't work with mgm
um actually he works um
can i tell you where he works
i'm gonna have to double check if i can
tell you what he works for
but anyway um it's a company that works
for studios i'll say that and and he
actually i he said
the one thing that hit me about you
might he watched my video from ages ago
and reason why he got touched me was he
said i used the phrase stargate is the
sleeping giant of sci-fi and he says
that phrase has been knocking around for
a while
um and he he says he goes to conventions
and things and not not conventions like
we do um conventions of what he does his
industry conventions and he gets asked
all the time why aren't they making
stargate
it was the biggest show mgm have ever
done why aren't they making another one
and he gets asked that all the time
it makes no sense at all that amazon
would spend eight billion dollars buying
mgm and then not use its second biggest
franchise it would be like amazon buying
mgm
and scrapping bond james bond you know
it would be like i'm not gonna have any
more it's it's it's a has been we don't
we're not going to bother or saying that
we're going to scrap the next creed3
movie or we're going to you know do
something else we won't bother making
another robocop film the the reason why
they bought
mgm was for projects like stargate they
will 100
be making the stargate series
it's just going to take a little bit
longer than we thought
so guys thank you so much i'm going to
see you
sliders should have been better the
first series of sliders was brilliant
um
but it did get a bit shittier
thanks again everybody please like
subscribe for the qualification join do
all that blood in there business and i
will see you later in the week and
definitely at the weekend we're going to
be doing a live show all about stargate
series 2 sg1 so please
get on it there
as always please stay safe
i'm going to see you very very soon
bye guys